we are seeing now climate impacts that
are tremendously costly and tremendously
challenging and EPA's role is to try to
make turn that challenge into a positive
message moving forward give communities
the tools they need to adapt you know
recognize that the time for action is
now so in many ways the the problem that
we had in the past was twofold people
didn't see the impacts as as much as
they're seeing them in feeling them
today
it wasn't already it's happening what do
I do and so we were predicting things
that might happen but it's taken so long
to take action those predictions are
already here and frankly we never
predicted the kind of impacts that we
are seeing today climate is always
portrayed on newscasts as being some
kind of big debate you know the big
debate among the scientists is that
seven ninety seven percent of them know
it's happening and are really worried
about it three percent are skeptical
that's not a balance that's an
overwhelming majority and that needs to
drive the decision especially in a
democracy that's how we work with
working really hard with faith leaders
in this country because many of the
people listen to their faith leaders for
direction and the faith leaders are
extremely concerned that climate change
is an issue which most importantly and
more significantly impacts low-income
and minority communities the least of
these are going to be the most impacted
in a changing climate so we are moving
with with an ecumenical constituency in
the faith community to bring this
message to their constituents and it's
extremely important to recognize your
own limitations about who who you're
good at talking to and who's going to
believe you and who the people you're
trying to influence listen to because we
can talk all we want about the science
at EPA but you need to put that into
people's homes and ears in a way that
they're going to listen absorb and know
they can be part of the solutions moving
forward that gets them off the diamond
bills the constituency's you need to
exceed and something this is that is
really as big as this the challenge of
climate change is enormous for us and so
you need to attack that from all
different angles and make sure to get
everybody engaged I don't need to fight
the climate deniers now that's not what
I think we need the rallying cry needs
to be what actions do we take that are
going to address climate both from you
know we need to mitigate and make sure
that we're reducing those impacts but
also let's do it in a way that grows a
low-carbon economy let's make the united
states flourish because we stood up to
this problem and we took action